ENTERTAINING GAME HERE TONIGHT
AGAINST TATAR
ENDED A NINE-GAME GOAL D D FORM!
BRENDANK.
PICTURE PERFECT PASS OVER TO
BRENDEN DILLON.
NOER THE LINE AND CONTROLLED BY
HUGHES.
JACK DROPS IT BACK.
TAKEN BACK BY SCHMIDT. FAST MOV
PERIOD TOO.
UNDER 9:00 TO PLAY IN THE FIRST.
TAKEN HERE. OF
MORRISSEY.
BASTIAN ON IT.
DEVILS  FIND THAT LOOSE PUCK WI
HIS STICK.
WATCH THIS RIGHT HERE.ONT.
DEANLEY.
>> Ken: DEVILS HAVE HAD A FEW
CHANCES ON THIS
THEM AND HE WEARS AN 8.
THE PICK
TO THE TASK.
>> Ken: COMRIE IS IN THE ZONE SO
THE PUCK.
HERE IS ONE TIMER AND HE SCORES!
A HIS
STICK.
NICE LITTLE ZONE THERE.
PEAAROUND.
I REALLY RESPECTED HIS CAREER
AND THE WAY.
HUGHES HAS A MAN A FAST TEAM.
BUT YOU GOT STAY WITH IT AND
KICK IT OUT WIT CLEAR
THE PUCK.
A FAST-PACED GAME.
BOTH TEAMS IT TO
THE STICK OF HUGHES.
IT WAS APPARENTLYZONE!
GIVES TOO REVERSE MOMENTUM.
SCHEIFELE ACROSS.
THERE IS CONNOR!
MOVING IN ON DAWS!
A PENALTY COMING UP!BACK OF
ON TZACHA. SIEGENTHALER AHEAD A
ZACHA TO THE STICK OF
>> Ken: TIME TO THE DRAW.
POWER PLAY THAT IS RANKED 13th
IN THE NHL COMING IN
CONNOR HELLEBUYCK.
INSHOT, WHAT A QUI